Dean and Sam Winchester. Mulder and Scully.
Wednesday and Thing. Every supernatural crime
solver needs a partner to back them up when
their back is against the wall, and it turns
out that being a disembodied hand comes in, well,
handy quite frequently. It also turns out that it
was an impressive feat to capture the effect on
film. Keep watching to find out how they did it.
Though Wednesday Addams did not intend
on careening down a rabbit hole when she
first enrolled in Nevermore Academy, fate
had other plans. The events of "Wednesday"
kick off upon the titular character's
immediate expulsion from High School.
Morticia and Gomez Addams ship her off
to where she can be among her peers:
a school for bizarre adolescents. Wednesday
fully intends on continuing her anti-social ways,
but this all changes when she sees a fellow
student murdered by a strange monster.
With the help of a childhood assistant,
Wednesday is on the case. At first,
Thing's contribution is slightly
unwilling as Wednesday treats him
like an insubordinate employee. But after a
time, Wednesday's walls fall and they become
true allies. Fans of the Tim Burton series
quickly became enamored with Thing, taking
to social media to praise Wednesday's helpful
and empathetic friend. One Reddit user wrote,
"Thing is brilliant. I love that Wednesday
has this one part of her family with her,
so she's never really alone."
"Wednesday" may be a modernized
version of the popular franchise,
but the Netflix series still involves
the classic hallmarks that delight fans.
It isn't long after Wednesday settles into
school that she discovers she isn't alone.
Thing first follows her at the behest of her
parents but soon joins her wild crusade with
his handsy skills. It may seem that the severed
appendage is only the result of computer graphics,
but that would be doing the man behind the
hand — Victor Dorobantu — a disservice.
Netflix revealed on Twitter that Thing
is portrayed by Dorobantu, who wears a
full-bodied blue suit to get the effect. With his
many scenes getting into hard-to-reach places,
the actor must contort and many times crawl on
the ground to get the shots needed. Dorobantu even
showed a video on his personal Instagram about the
process of filming one specific underwater scene.
While these efforts may seem tedious, there
is no doubt that it ultimately gets results.
Wednesday would never be one to admit it, but
she needs Thing. Her antisocial schtick only
gets her so far, and Thing represents a support
system that never judges her. From sneaking her
into morgues to getting her a dress for the
dance, Thing has proven his devotion to his
spooky mistress, making him one of the
most likable characters in "Wednesday."
Victor Dorobantu's behind-the-scenes photos
as Thing have taken the internet by storm,
with many praising the actor for his difficult
role. "SNL" alum Laraine Newman
took to Twitter in awe, saying,
"I'm sincerely marveling at
the actor playing Thing on
Netflix's Wednesday ... Victor
Dorobantu's work is stunning."
With Dorobantu on everyone's mind,
one can't help but wonder: who is he?
In the wake of Thing's popularity,
Dorobantu discussed his "Wednesday" role in
a candid chat with Vanity Fair. The 25 year
old magician had this to say about
the viral behind-the-scenes photos,
"I didn't know we had so many
photos of me behind the scenes.
It's kind of interesting to see that even for me."
Would fans believe that "Wednesday" is Dorobantu's
first acting gig? A closeup magician by trade in
his native Romania, Dorobantu ended
up at a casting house in Bucharest,
where he was chosen as a finalist for
the role amongst two other magicians.
What nabbed him the role? The magician
has no idea. The actor told the outlet,
"I wish that Tim [Burton] would
tell me what he saw in me."
What the trickster does know is that he and
the series creator got along swimmingly,
recounting how his hand began to take
on a life of its own on a table while
chatting with Burton for the first time. He said,
"So I guess Tim saw in front of him an actor and
the hand separately. So it was a
connection from the first moment."